well it's great to have you in here one
of my favorites of course are you gonna
do acoustically is all the young dudes
it's a bowie tune and you came to record
that song because you were gonna break
up your band right at the time and it
was done it was over it was over and
Bowie was a fan of yours that's fine the
guy was stuff for jet silly we did well
you do this and I said and we listened
and we thought no you know cuz lady I
was pretty much close to us we had three
singles nothing we knew it was gonna I
was looking for something like you
really got me that's what I was looking
for right and why did Bowie offer you
suffragette City one of his best songs I
guess because it was before it had been
recorded right I think it was because he
thought it was a rocker and we were
welcomed all by and you know he felt you
would have done it better than him I
don't know who knows you're not stars
Dave are you not are you not not
flattered that a guy of David Bowie's
stature would say to you I need you to
do one of my songs no he was just some
little gazer in Beckenham you know he
was and he brought you all the young
dude he sat down and played it on an
acoustic guitar rather like I'm about to
do yes he to things I thought the first
thing was I can sing this and the second
thing was like I've never been behind a
hip before right and it's a funny
feeling because nobody else has ever
heard this you know and then I'm sitting
there with the band you know and we're
listening to this and it's like it's
obvious I love hearing you do this but
this is something different we're gonna
do it acoustically right yeah all right
here we go I'll sit quiet I'm not gonna
jump in at any point well you're welcome
to do it and thank you
[Music]
Billy laughs all night about suicide
I'll be kicking in my head when he reads
25
speech I've stylize
we're 25
Ramar to sparks and Freddy's got spots
been driven off the stars from the stage
[Music]
funky little bye
his crazy
in equal rights oh man
[Music]
oh brother again
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
nestle looks weight cuz she dresses like
a queen she can kick like a mule
that's our well-maintained
awaken laugh
[Music]
with his beetles and he stands we never
got it up
I'll never revolution step what a drag
too many
by drunk a lot of wine I'm feeling fire
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
come on Alan you ready
all the young booze a carrot
[Music]
carry on
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful see
[Music]
I never get tired of hearing that song
if you did it a hundred thousand times
sitting there I would never get tired of
that song it is beautiful